und dann ist mir bewusst geworden ich
stehe auf jungs 19 yard richtig gehört
ich stehe auf jungs er ohne wird seite
diese ganze sache
ich kann das nicht ich kann das ganze
nicht für 100 prozent voll nimmt ja das
hat schon gesehen wir uns heute ein
video anschauen was ein bisschen anders
ist als die sachen die man sonst
anschauen und zwar werden wir heute
einen blick in das outing von mega
bewerten nur damit wir alle beim
kenntnisstand sind heute kurzes intro
miguel paris/new eigentlich immer schon
recht kontrovers diskutiert wurde dann
hat er öffentlich seinen breakdown eine
psychose durch drogen weil ich war auch
an der klinik relativ heftige story
insgesamt und letzten tagen liter wieder
regelmäßige hoch unter anderem eben auch
dieses video in dem er sich outet auf
dem sammler küsst er seinen neuen freund
schon war er hat wohl ziemlich viel hält
dafür abbekommen das video steht aktuell
bei 60 prozent des lakers geisteskrank
vieles bei youtube verhältnisse deswegen
werden jetzt mal einen vernünftigen
blick reinwerfen ging es los
heute habe ich ein sehr sehr ernstes
thema mit euch zu besprechen und ich
weiß es wird sehr sehr viele von euch
schockieren und ich habe mega angst vor
diesem video das kann ich schon mal
direkt gut nachvollziehen muss ich sagen
denn ich glaube mir papa hat eine
community die bisschen aus der jetzt
wenig falsch verstehen sozialeren ecke
von youtube kommt also ich glaube das
ist eine community die es sehr sehr
negativ aufnimmt wenn männer oder jungs
sich in der öffentlichkeit äußern und
sagen ja wisst ihr was so ich stehe auf
männer anders machen sie ja auch 63.000
wissen lag 240 tausend likes ist eine
heftige ansage und leute ich weiß nicht
wie das ankommt wird und deswegen ich
fange jetzt einfach an zu erzählen damit
die mich mal versteht so wir müssen bei
der ganzen sache aber auch dazu sagen
ich kenne den aktuellen
gesundheitszustand von mir geld nicht
was ich meine ist man darf nicht
vergessen dass eben diese vergangenheit
hat mit ya sein manisch depressiven
phasen und also ich würde alles und zwar
im best gemeinden sinne erst mal
kritisch sehen was mir gefahren der
öffentlichkeit sagt aber ich habe auch
mega angst davor das video hier zu
machen weil ich meinen community kenne
genau das ist nämlich genau das was ich
mache also erst selbst kennt natürlich
auch seine community wenn nicht sogar
ich als außenstehender youtuber denn
nicht viel geld aber schaut das sagen
kann dass seine community das helfen
wird
dann weiß er ist erst recht so es war
schon glaube ich relativ klar dass das
unglück kommt aber egal ich erzähle euch
jetzt einfach mal einen situation und
ich hoffe einfach ihr versteht mich und
die wahren fans von mir die werden mich
so akzeptieren wie ich bin und ich werde
mich auch nicht verändern die topleute
alten losgelöst davon dass wir nicht
genau wissen was in seinem kopf vorgeht
und was die motive die motivation für
sein video ist ich finde es schon
relativ krass dass wenn man in 2009 10
ende 2009 sogar ein video hochlädt indem
man sagt ja ich wollte nur sagen ich bin
schwul so ich habe mehr bock auf jungs
als auch mädchen das das denn so eine
krasse negative reaktion auslöst
jedenfalls habe ich jemanden kennenlernt
wir waren erst sehr gute freunde
und dann kam das eine zum anderen also
ihr wisst ich bleibe es bei diesem video
aber diese story ist auf jeden fall
schon mal lust ist ja aber ist einfach
immer so
man hat so ein brot zu mit dem und dann
kommt man irgendwann mit dem zusammen
habe ich jetzt in der form auch noch
nicht gehört aber wie gesagt also jedem
das seine wenn das für ihn sich so
entwickelt hat save und ich muss ich
muss ich wirklich sagen
noch mal ich finde es kraft wie negativ
die reaktion darauf ist also wo ist der
grund dass du das leben so besteht halt
nicht erfahren so und ich habe einfach
anders geführt als ich sonst geführt
habe und dann ist mir bewusst geworden
ich stehe auf jungs eher 19 yard richtig
gehört ich stehe auf jungs was man
definitiv dazu sagen muss leute ist
respekt an ihn dafür dass er das so
öffentlich nach außen trägt er sich der
tatsache bewusst dass er würde
wahrscheinlich homophobe community hat
also der gemütlich mit schwulsein nicht
klarkommt hat sie aber trotzdem dazu
entschieden das noch auszutragen hätte
es vielleicht ja auch verheimlichen
können
dafür muss man schon mal seine emotionen
ist zwar nicht schlecht und ja
eigentlich ist das kein trauriges video
weil ich eigentlich sehr aufgeregt
werden weil denjenigen den ich
kennengelernt habe haben einige schon in
meinem video gestern gesehen ich habe
ihn gestern zum ersten mal gezeigt wir
haben das gleichzeitig brakes gemacht
und ja leute zeigt euch jetzt mal in
aller erster freund ok bevor der freund
reinkommt leute eine sache die der
ganzen sache hier so ein bisschen
bitteren beigeschmack gibt ehrlich
gesagt ist das was er am nächsten tag
hochgeladen hat
dieses video von mir weisen die autos
kam vor zwei tagen ins gestern hatte
noch ein video hochgeladen und guck mal
das video von gestern heißt schon haben
wir schon miteinander
ich weiß nicht dann am nächsten tag und
video zu machen wo man das so ausnutzt
ausschlachtet für aufmerksamkeit auch
noch so eine plumpe art und weise ich
weiß nicht egal dass ich muss sagen das
gefällt mir nicht so
das freilich nicht ja leute so ist es
halt wo die liebe hinfällt
es ist halt so da findest du die
richtige person und tag hast du
plötzlich gefühle für ihn falls da
draußen irgendwelche gibt die auch sowas
hat habe keine angst davor euch sorten
es fällt ein riesenstein vom herzen das
ist definitiv eine botschaft supporten
kann leute wir leben zwar im jahr 2009
10 aber die reaktion von seiner köpfelte
ihr drauf zeigt schon sehr gut wie
manche leute noch über dieses thema
denken
ich glaube kette nicht als jemand der
sehr tolerant ist ich persönlich habe
kein interesse an jungs mit den
romantischen sich in sexueller hinsicht
aber ich würde den teufel tun hier mal
anlass dafür fertig zu machen dass er
keine ahnung auf männer steht so what
the [ __ ] erlebt ihr im steinzeitalter
kommt man klar auf erleben ja es war
auch irgendwie genauso wie er gesagt hat
schon vorher wer hat das interesse so
langsam an girls verloren wenn ich ihnen
so anschaue dann fühle ich irgendwas
anderes ein stück weit kann ich das
nachvollziehen kann man einfach
der ganze scheiße die man erlebt mädels
ihr mädels hab das mit sicherheit
gleichermaßen mit jungs erlebte da denkt
man sich irgendwann leiter ich habe
schon soviel also schlafen jetzt nicht
ernsthaft aber wir wissen noch nicht was
ich meine aber keine nahrung wir haben
nicht gemerkt wir haben die gefühle
füreinander wir haben eher miteinander
gequatscht als irgendwie zeit mit
anderen mädels zu verbringen ja wir
haben uns ein glas geteilt so einfach
irgendwann war es so da war mädchen bei
uns nur wir beide haben gerät ist ja und
die anderen haben wir komplett
ausgeblendet und das macht es auch so
also aus na ja ich muss sagen leute so
als außenstehender ohne jetzt den beide
die köpfe rein schauen zu können und
auch wenn ich das mal ausbilden dass er
jetzt direkt danach sind video
hochgeladen hat was wirklich so mega
plump ist und in so eine richtung geht
die überhaupt nicht verrät ist sowas
erstmal was megaschön ist denke ich na
also man sieht ja an direkt in seiner
community dass er davor wohl ziemlich
schiss gehabt hat
sich so sich so zu öffnen und das zu
zeigen ich glaube wenn man das dann
macht ist es erstmal was recht befreien
das so es ist natürlich scheiße
community hat die 14 60.000 bis max
reindl für sowas einfach nur wenn man
auch andere sachen steht als sie
vielleicht aber ich glaube im ersten
feld ist etwas befreiendes tatsächlich
damit ihr das jetzt klar steht sowie
haben uns in der nacht geküsst
das war nicht so komisch war so sehr was
schön ist er ist so schön wir haben
erstmal gar nicht darüber geredet wir
dachten sowie sagen dass gar kein also
ich muss noch mal sagen heute wirklich
krasse schritt von ihm dass er in der
form und in der deutlichkeit da so ein
video darüber macht und ich will mich
noch an alle leute richten die auch so
denken das ist vielleicht da ein dislike
geben wird oder tatsächlich in whistler
gegeben haben ich glaube in meiner
community leute bei euch gibt es wenige
davon die so denkt da wir sind schon
recht tolerant weil keine ahnung
vielleicht auch andere leute schauen was
mich aber draußen jemand ist der hier
vielleicht ein display gegeben hätte
dann bis leck gegeben hat broders ist
warum also ich kann verstehen irgendwo
dass das vielleicht ein thema ist was
dich irritiert sowohl vor du angst hast
du denkst soma warum macht er das so ich
selbst könnte das nicht machen aber
sowie als menschheit können nur
miteinander existieren wenn wir anderen
halt einfach die freiheit zugestehen
das zu machen was für sie richtig ist
und dann haben wir einfach mal we talk
nacht wir haben gesagt dass wir gefühle
füreinander haben und seitdem sind wir
halt jeden tag zusammen unterwegs
treffen uns bei ihm öfter ich trage es
hätte pullis unser freundeskreis muss
ist auch nicht bitte schreibt uns wegen
dem video jetzt nicht so komische
nachrichten von wegen etwas los mit euch
und so das wollen wir gar nicht lesen er
ohne wird sollte diese ganze sache
ich kann das nicht ich kann das ganze
nicht für hundert prozent von dem
versteht was ich meine damit meine ich
nicht dass ich unbedingt denke oder
davon ausgehen dass das nicht seine
echten gefühle sind aber das alles
nachdem zeug was miguel hochgeladen hat
keine ahnung die videos wo er in der
badewanne geschlafen hat wo er auf dem
alexanderplatz ihr video gedreht hat
dann irgendwie mitten in der
menschenmenge seine hosen runterlässt um
tattoo zu zeigen so musikvideo also ich
sagen ob ich denke so ich sage ja
hoffentlich denke so ich kann das
irgendwie nicht so ganz
wir können ja erzählen wir haben es ja
unseren beiden besten freunden
wir haben den besten freunden erzählt
also bei dem coming-out wo wir darüber
mit denen gesprochen haben
echt schockiert darüber und das ist uns
im endeffekt nicht gleich gefallen genau
wie das jetzt hier der einhard sehr cool
genommen der usa steht doch dahinter
magdeburg das bleibt alles wie länder
notwendig wie sind die selbe person ja
ist letzten endes auch so also wie
gesagt ich glaube viel von dieser
schwulenfeindlichkeit kommt daher dass
leute selbst einfach schiss haben selbst
so zu sein weil ihre väter oder
großväter damit er ihnen eingetrichtert
haben so ja so darf auf gar keinen fall
sein so ist man nicht und dann denken
sie sich okay ich will nicht zu sagen
das will ich so sein so auf gar keinen
fall
und deswegen pushen sie das erst recht
wenn so etwas sehen was aber auch
verständlich ist aber man sollte halt
schon genug hirn im kopf haben und
irgendwann zu checken okay ich würde
darauf trainiert das schlecht zu finden
aber vielleicht ist es gar nicht so
schlecht wenn ihr es wollt dann lasst
nike dass wir halt ein kartell machen
und vielleicht machen wir dann mehr
videos und jeder der schwulenfeindlichen
den kommentaren ist zeigt ihnen das
schwulenfeindlichkeit nicht okay ist
dieses video wird hoffentlich zeigen wie
stark die leute gegen diskriminierung
sind ja leider nicht
das ist komplett nach hinten losgegangen
es war 42.000 likes was aber ultra wenig
ist für 87.000 aufrufe und dagegen
stehen einfach 63.000 discs also dass
sie dieses video ich genau das gegenteil
gezeigt nämlich dass ein gewisser teil
von deutschland und ich glaube so diese
leute die auch so kanal und die miguel
pablo schauen das sind vielleicht auch
so ähnliche die auch genauer angeschaut
haben früher oder so da hat leute
geschaut haben die diese ansichten
vertreten so dass man nicht schwul sein
darf oder so was diese leute leben halt
noch ein bisschen hinter mond man muss
wirklich sagen die leben bis hinterm und
bist einfach so und damit wir beleidigen
oder so man muss auch will ich auch mal
ein klares statement setzen so im jahr
2019 lebt man hinterm mond wenn man
jemanden hated dafür dass er sagt dass
er schwul ist
er ist einfach so hier kriegt ein
persönlich für die vorgeschlagene video
hier um könnte man kann an der stelle
heraus schaffen wir gerne eure meinung
in die kommentare
macht's gut